let's move on to the broncos patriots
yeah it's a low point for pac for
patriots fans uh my goodness you know of
all the teams that i thought would be
able to handle the unpredictability the
uncertainty of the pandemic it was the
new england patriots but that was not to
be let's hear some of the sound coming
out of yesterday's home loss to the
denver broncos 18 to 12.
nobody cares you know about
what the it was or what the reasons were
and and to be honest with you i don't
care either i'm not expecting people to
care you know my job here moving forward
is to find ways to win football games to
put this team in the best situation and
it just starts with protecting the
football and that's what this game came
down to how much did the limited amount
of
fully padded practice time you've had in
recent weeks do you feel had on today's
game
i don't know but you want a percentage
i have no idea
always happy at least he's no different
in victory than he is in defeat i had
somebody email me last night why do
people tolerate that why is that
appropriate for him to treat
professionals that way and we're just
numb to it because he's got eight rings
but
really in what profession is it
acceptable to be that dismissive of
somebody who's just trying to do their
job and i've said this before and let me
say it again if he doesn't like that
then he should go coach high school
lacrosse where nobody cares and nobody's
gonna want to talk to him and he doesn't
have to deal with the media and not be a
butthole and i almost said the other
word you can say him separately you
can't say him together i almost said why
does he have to but why does he have to
be that way chris and why do we put up
with it no because he's the greatest
coach of all time and there's no denying
that i mean what he does is amazing that
way it's it is the worst thing about him
though yes i don't know i don't know why
he fights it he wasn't always that way
you go back to the early days he was
very charismatic when he saw him in
cleveland or the jets or the patriots
you know press conferences things that
way uh i don't know why why he's like
that it is the one side of him that it
does bother me i can't lie as a guy
that's a fan of bill belichick and known
him for a long long time i don't know
why he
treats people like that either at times
i don't get it
yeah i mean i get the the awkwardness
that you see from her from time to time
in the interpersonal relationships you
know the guy who as you've said you're
walking down the hallway at the facility
and he's like up against the wall i mean
that's a quirkiness but yeah there's
just a there's a meanness that flashes
from time to time and and i just don't
think you should treat other
professionals that way in that type of a
setting so let's talk about the game
i can understand why he was upset his
offense uh couldn't do much of anything
the broncos did their best to let them
hang around you know usually in a game
like that chris when you see field goal
field goal field goal field goal field
goal you just assume it's a matter of
time yes before the other team starts
scoring touchdowns and you're done and
that never quite happened it almost
happened yes but they weren't quite able
to get it done well that's it it almost
did happen you're right i mean first off
i mean drew hey drew lock he came out
made some great throws to start the game
kind of got them going and jump started
that way but i think ultimately the the
theme of the game was
yeah lackluster drives by new england
and here's the drive chart if you you
know if you're watching with denver it
wasn't like a really impressive day but
they got points and they didn't make a
lot of mistakes until the end of the
football game and you see those two
interceptions which gave cam newton and
everybody a little life but we don't
we're not used to seeing the patriots
like be sloppy like that
two interceptions you know there's
another point you go okay here they go
izzo catches the tight end izzo catches
a big catch down the middle of the field
fumbles right on the edge of field goal
position they're getting a first down
then it's another drive and you're going
okay here they go they got their mojo
you know the snap over cam newton's head
that knocks them out of field goal range
so there was a lot i mean it showed hey
we saw one team last week in the
tennessee titans who miraculously went
out and played like the cleanest
football game and looked like they
didn't miss a beat new england's been
through a lot of crap the last two weeks
and it showed it really did there's
still a new team too with a lot of new
missing parts i think we forget that
because the uniforms and belichick are
there and everything stayed the same but
you know i think with cam newton as the
quarterback and some of these young
receivers
and all the guys they got that are
different on the defensive side of the
ball it showed that they're a team that
is not complete they're still a work in
progress and this is sloppy as i've seen
them in a long time
and if you can't practice how do you get
yourself ready to play the covet 19
situation again i thought the patriots
would be the last team to be affected by
this in a negative way they'd have a
plan for everything but with all of the
issues they've had starting with cam
newton a couple of weeks ago it was fine
they were clean everything was great it
looked like they were going to have a
positive all year long it's gonna be fun
they've cracked the code on covet 19.
yeah it started two and a half weeks ago
uh with co with with cam newton and uh
you know when you just don't play when
he doesn't play and they don't play it's
actually was it three weeks ago that
this yeah it's been three weeks since
cam
newton's yeah he's played three weeks
for him they've been dealing with the
issues they've got interior offensive
linemen like james ferentz who who's on
the cove at 19. they've got a bunch of
guys on the covet 19 list and and we're
seeing what happens when you're the one
team
that is having these issues and we're
going to talk about the titans coming up
it makes it even more impressive what
they've been able to do
dealing with their own issues the
patriots haven't been able to deal with
it i mean you take the titans out of the
building for 16 days they're championing
at the bit to get back and start kicking
people's butts you take the patriots
away and they feel lost well yeah i mean
listen hey the titans are a more
talented football team than the patriots
that's that's not a question and it's
pretty much the same team from last year
too so they at least have that unity and
as we know they also snuck away and had
a few practices by themselves so
you know they did they did do that but
they have that advantage you know new
england like we said with all the opt
outs of the cobin 19 different people in
the front seven all that they got they
got to coach those guys up some of those
guys like you know are early in their
career too so kovan 19 you know is
taking away the patriots greatest
element of their football team and this
little bit of a semi-rebuild year right
where they were going to kind of like
rebuild but probably still be ten and
six and go to the playoffs or something
but the biggest advantage new england
has as a football team
is
bill belichick and the fact that he
can't be in the meetings and hey we're
going to do this walk through and
remember to look for this and hey
coaches did you coach him to do this
because we got to worry about this when
they're that that's the greatest
strength of their football team and
that's lost through zoom meetings yeah
he's still coaching and doing all that
but not the way and to the extent new
england likes to get things done and
what separates themselves from the pack
so to me yeah it's a tough one for them
and they're gonna it's gonna continue to
be a battle because the offense is a
work in progress and everything like
that
first time below 500 this late into the
season since 2001.
now 2001 worked out pretty well yeah
they eventually found their groove and
that's the silver lining if you're a
patriots fan
they still can figure this out they
still can get it together i remember i
think it was and this game came up last
night because
drew locke throwing multiple
interceptions and his team still winning
at new england was only the second time
in the belichick era that's happened the
other time week 10 2001. kurt warner
with the rams i think it was a sunday
night game the the rams won
the patriots fell to five and five right
and then they matched on the gas pedal
after that so there's still time just
hang around 500 until thanksgiving let
belichick do his thing in december yeah
hope you can have three practices a week
to prepare for each game
you get guys off of the covet 19 list by
then and look i'm still not ready to
give up on the new england patriots
until they're dead it's like the time i
did it last year yeah the terminator
never dies until he's dead like he was
against the titans right but i'm not i
think you i think the worst thing you
can do is assume they're done at two and
three there's a lot of
like you said if they can practice get a
little healthy here on the offensive
line
there's still a lot to like about their
football team as crappy as they play
they had a chance there yesterday i mean
an nfl football game as crappy as that
was and as beat up as they were they did
have a chance uh i mean you're right
about that and we've seen hey without
cam newton they had the kansas city
chiefs on the ropes wobbly they were on
the one foot yard line versus the
seahawks who were all like saying is the
best team in the nfc so they shouldn't
give up hope they got to remember that
the only thing i worry about mike and a
little something i brought up on
football night in america last night the
afc is so damn good it's unbelievable
and i just worry about them like falling
too far behind to where
you know this could be one of those
years where you you got the colts right
now as a seventh seed who end up being
like you know ten and six in in the
playoffs i mean the afc is just so good
we had those discussions there's no
middle class really in the nfl it's like
there's a lot of really awesome and
there's a lot of really crap and i worry
about that aspect as far as the the
patriots playoffs hopes a little bit
the denver broncos are trying to move
from the latter category to the former
category and look we got to give them
some credit yeah we did get the win even
though as vic fangio told me after the
game head coach the team biggest win so
far that he's had obviously as the coach
of the denver broncos you're not going
to beat the chiefs next weekend if you
can't score touchdowns negative goals
you've got to score touchdowns you can't
swap field goals for patrick holmes
doing what patrick mahomes does but but
you know this has to be the kind of game
chris that gives a team some confidence
that they can do something positive and
you know it's not like they get blown
out by the chiefs every time they play
them i think that if you're the broncos
there's a way
to to glean from what they were able to
do yesterday especially defensively that
they can maybe slow down the chiefs but
like we saw last week between the
raiders and the chiefs you slow them
down a little bit but you still have to
outscore them so it's both sides of the
coin that need to be taken care of but
the defense gave the broncos a lot of
reasons to be happy yesterday against
the patriots now the offense is gonna
have to step up to make it two in a row
yeah and actually it would be three in a
row right because they hadn't played
since that thursday night against the
jets you're right well i think the first
thing that we need to like when you're
right we gotta give denver credit we got
to give drew locke you know because
everybody's just going to see the
interceptions at the end of the game
though drew locke was a big part of why
they got off to a good start too now it
wasn't like he just blew but he made a
few throws where it totally flipped the
field position i bet you it made new
england go wait do we really want to
play man to man and get in the face of
these guys today because lock seems like
he's totally comfortable throwing
40-yard lasers down the field i mean he
had 10 completions for 189 yards so that
just tells you what kind of throws he
was attempting they were pushing the
ball down the field and then fangio he's
a mastermind that way and you're right
there's some there's things alike i mean
simmons and jackson at the back end of
the safety position you know they're
pretty good in the secondary there
bradley chubb popped a few times
yesterday i don't think they're ready
for kansas city prime time but with that
quarterback and some of the young pieces
have denver is one of those teams where
you just go man i'm excited about what
they could be in the future
and they've been through plenty of
adversity just like the the patriots and
you know they had a a running backs
coach curtis modkins land on covet 19 on
saturday you know it seems like there's
six seven teams that just have this
thing constantly swirling around and
they can't get away from it and i feel
like when they do someone else will step
in to that spot and it's just gonna like
migrate around the league all year long
and maybe come back around to some of
these teams and it's just amazing to see
how it's blossomed into its own separate
right
chunk of the news coverage at one point
on on friday or saturday like every top
story was coveted 19 related whether
it's the falcons whether it's the
jaguars but
a lot of teams and really most teams
haven't had issues that's what makes it
so glaring with that handful that do but
kudos to the broncos for dealing with
the distractions dealing with the issues
and getting things taken care of and uh
the patriots gonna have some work to do
but but first and foremost got to be
able to practice and if you can't
practice you can't get a work in
progress rebuild team ready to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports